[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture et tout de
suite le sommaire de ce mercredi 5
octobre praline gay para et conteuse
depuis deux ans elle fait découvrir des
récits du monde entier aux saint
quentinois sur scène ou en caravane le
faiseur est l'une des rares pièces le
théâtre écrite par honoré de balzac
l'oeuvre a été mise en scène par les
tréteaux de france une troupe de théâtre
et centre national dramatique et jouer
sur la scène du théâtre alphonse daudet
de poil hier mardi soir et nous
reviendrons aussi sur le premier concert
de la saison à la batterie de guyancourt
sages comme des sauvages evans mais
était sur scène
un conte populaire est de tradition
orale sans date connus et anonymes
travelling et parra en a fait sa vie
cette conteuse a entamé sa deuxième
résidence avec la ferme de bel ébat elle
propose des spectacles sur la scène
billon courtoise mais pas seulement
puisque elle sillonne aussi la ville
avec une caravane ça se passe lors des
manifestations culturelles ou
associatives et nous l'avons rencontré
regarder une petite caravane rouge mais
un grand voyage voilà ce que propose
praliné gay-para avec de petites
histoires de dix minutes elle vous
invite dans sa petite bulle dans son
imaginaire chacun va où il veut c'est ça
qui est bien dans la caravane
contrairement aux avions on a une
destination commune et six manches
propose une histoire et chacun fait le
voyage qui souhaite ou pas en résidence
depuis la saison dernière à guyancourt
praliné gay-para s'inspire de ces
rencontres pour composer sa découverte
du conte remonte elle à ses études en
ethno linguistique
crimes
liés creek
voilà là les oreilles sont bien en passe
d'être l'eau j'ai fait une thèse sur des
comptes que j'ai collecté au liban au
beau milieu de la guerre civile fin des
années 70 début des années 80 et j'ai
attrapé le virus verbalement
transmissibles incurable et au bout d'un
moment j'en avais plus envie de parler
des comptes j'avais envie de raconter
voilà pour découvrir les récits de
praliné gay-para rendez vous le 26
octobre à la maison de quartier théodore
monod compte merveilleuse ou fantastique
vous y attendent
le mardi 4 octobre le théâtre alphonse
daudet à coignières accueilli les
tréteaux de france la compagnie
itinérante et centre dramatique national
joué le faiseur l'une des rares pièce
écrite par le célèbre écrivain français
honoré de balzac si elle a été conçue en
1840 en parlant de dettes et de
spéculation elle n'a jamais été aussi
actuel regardez
[Musique]
mes devoirs
monsieur mercadé et banquiers as de la
tromperie il gère l'insistance de ses
créanciers mais cette fois il est acculé
c'est le monde des affaires qui est en
train de naître à ce moment là et
le monde des affaires des affairistes et
surtout maskinongé beaucoup dans cette
pièce c'est toute la dimension qui est
très liée à
à l'excitation du jeu en fait le faiseur
que je bruno cadillon personnage devenu
ce mercredi
donc s'appelle le faiseur son nouveau
défenseur mais c'est un
un grand joueur addictif
ça parle de l'anc risque on peut avoir
sur les autres
[Musique]
adapté par évelyne l'homme est mis en
scène par robin renucci le directeur des
tréteaux de france le faiseur ces deux
heures d'une pièce millimétré et sans
temps mort une comédie grinçante ou la
composition d'acteur prend toute son
ampleur c'est une comédie particulière
parce que elle travaille sur plusieurs
genres qui à la fois du burlesque du
mélodrame de la comédie de caractères la
commune des situations ou presque du
masque cirque on est extrêmement
maquillé comme comme des masques avec
des perruques très particulière des
costumes qui seront très marqués qui
sont prêts dans le style à la daumier
spéculation tromperies mensonges et
manipulations plus d'un siècle nous
séparent de l'écriture et pourtant la
pièce semble intemporel il ya énormément
de matière dans le texte de balzac qui
est très riche qui est vraiment
extraordinaire il faut imaginer qu'il a
écrit en 1840 et que c'est un texte qui
est complètement moderne quand il ya eu
la ferme addow là il ya quelques années
le faiseur ils ont ressorti et est
marqué la ferme haddock écrite par
balzac en 1840 c'est pour dire comme il
était vraiment visionnaire avec de
l'énergie et du rocambolesque monsieur
mercadé n'a pas fini de nous interroger
sur un problème de société
ils ont joué dans une fan zone lors de
l'euro 2016 sages comme des sauvages
sont passionnés de voyages et donnent à
leurs compositions une couleur
internationale
il était sur la scène de la batterie à
guyancourt vendredi dernier et nous les
avons rencontrés regardez
dans le noir est signataire c'est tout
les six jolies la place de leader et
chanteur
du folk bâtard de la musique des
antipodes c'est leur propre définition
sages comme des sauvages c'est une
musique cosmopolite involontaire on
n'est pas contre on est content de faire
ça mais ça c'est vraiment par hasard
mais comme nos vies qu enfin moi je ma
mère est américaine mon père est
français et j'ai grandi en grèce donc
déjà sa c3 identité que j'ai pas choisi
c'est comme ça et puis ils se mêlent
c'est un peu pareil ça s'est baladé par
tous on récolte un peu ce qu'il nous
plaît on ne le mélange a new way
des identités diverses du bouzouki
grecque au cavaquinho brésilien de leurs
influences éclectiques qu'ils écrivent
et composent au gré de leur rencontre et
de leur voyage
juste
[Musique]
ce soir on est un quatuor est alors on a
trouvé une bassoniste en covoiturage ça
ça va mais moi j'ai trouvé un mexicain à
bruxelles qui ajoute plein d'instruments
bizarres voilà presque pareil tu
t'entends bien tu fais de la musique
voici ça marche y a pas on essaye de
passes dire tiens il faudrait qu'on ait
une basse une batterie guitare et un
clavier pour faire un truc
[Musique]
des mélodies métissé pour un voyage
autour du monde avec une escale vendredi
dernier à la batterie de guyancourt
[Musique]
il me manque
et lors de ce même concert la première
partie était assurée par grain s'aimer
le groupe créé au début des années 2000
propose un style musical à mi chemin
entre les chansons des îles de l'océan
indien et le rock électro écoutez le
chanteur du groupe il revient sur l'
influence de l'île de la réunion dans
les paroles et les rites il était au
micro de camille lambert ce qui est
important c'est de se respecter soi-même
nous on est on est mélangé moi je sais
que j'ai une grande partie
réunionnaise et j'ai une grande partie
française aussi puisque mes parents sont
installés à la réunion à 50 ans et donc
du coup j'ai eu ces deux cultures gcdt
double culture c'est pour ça que je
chante en français ou en créole
donc c'est assez important oui c'est
important ce qui est important c'est
surtout la diversité
[Musique]
je crois
conte
[Musique]
on prend maintenant la direction des
clayes-sous-bois puisque cette semaine
le coup de coeur du professionnel c'est
siri la date de l'espace philippe barret
écoutez cette semaine notre coup de
coeur et le film français réalisé par
françois ozon avec paula bear et pierre
niney au lendemain de la guerre 14 18
dans une petite ville allemande anna se
rend tous les jours sur la tombe de son
fiancé france mort sur le front en
france mais ce jour là un jeune français
adrien est venu se recueillir sur la
tombe de son ami allemand
cette présence à la suite de la défaite
allemande va provoquer des réactions
passionnelles dans la vie le réalisateur
de huit femmes nous bouleverse dans son
nouveau film un mélo historique qui se
déroule juste après la guerre 14-18
france est un film intense et rapide
d'une densité inouïe l'interprétation
est précise et la mise en scène élégante
le spectateur tombera sous la séduction
de paul à bir jeune actrice allemande et
véritable révélation du film pierre
niney trouve l'un de ses meilleurs rôles
le film est l'une des plus grandes
réussites de françois ozon france est
incontestablement la sensation de la
rentrée et est à découvrir cette semaine
à l'espace philippe noiret
à
et comme chaque semaine plusieurs dates
culturel à noter le 17 octobre sur la
scène du prisme vous pourrez découvrir à
bichat icône trio des places sont
d'ailleurs à y aller avec tv fil 78
toutes les informations sur la page
facebook de la chaîne et vous avez
jusqu'au 10 octobre pour participer et
si jamais vous ne pouvez pas voir le
concert il sera diffusé sur notre
antenne regardez cet extrait
[Musique]
quand
non
et ce week-end c'est le retour du
festival de la bd à buc les 8 et 9
octobre prochains une cinquantaine
d'auteurs qu'ils soient pour les adultes
ou pour la jeunesse qu'il soit aussi
français ou internationaux seront là
pour rencontrer les fans au château de
la commune et pour les amateurs de danse
et le ballet de l'opéra de lyon qui se
produit les 6 et 7 octobre au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ce sont deux
soirées pour découvrir ou redécouvrir le
sind aljibe une grande figure de la
danse contemporaine
regardez cet extrait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la maison elsa triolet aragon et la
compagnie théâtre et voile vous propose
de tenter de percer l'énigme elsa
triolet la romancière épouse du poète
aragon est le point central de l'unique
représentation de ce dimanche 9 octobre
et on termine ce magazine avec un
dernier rendez vous c'est le 14 octobre
avec l'auteur compositeur interprète
thomas fersen il lancera la saison du
scarabée de la verrière avant d'écouter
un extrait je vous souhaite une très
bonne soirée et je vous dis à mercredi
prochain on me dit que je suis paresseux
que je ne fais que ce que je veux
[Musique]
c'est à dire pas grand chose
on dit que je un report je suis
je
m
je n'ai
[Musique]